recording in progress I can see narayana
has joined from Bangalore hi I can see
bhavna from mahastra High Palmer
I'm just giving introduction again for
folks who have just joined now and are
still joining as you can see uh so
meanwhile keep introductions coming in
before we start
I can see Aditya has joined from Bihar I
can see someone is joined from Hyderabad
as well
I can see Sunil has went from Gujarat
so hello everyone so we'll be starting
the session uh just in few minutes uh
meanwhile just get settled in uh
wherever you're joining from I can see
Karthik has joined from guntu
and I can see Sunil has joined from
Gujarat
awesome awesome uh like uh keep uh the
introductions coming in meanwhile we
will start the session
we'll just take few more minutes uh to
start the session
I can see Augustine has joined from
England he hype I can see part two from
Bangalore
awesome uh welcome everyone we'll be
starting in just few minutes
so meanwhile what you can do is you can
utilize this time if you have a question
you can put out your question in the Q a
box uh if you want to introduce yourself
I would love to know where you're
joining from and I'm pretty sure though
folks who have joined here as well uh
they're pretty warm and welcome again I
can see from the chat here uh I can see
uh introductions coming in on chat
so would like to know where you're
joining from before we start just in few
minutes
I can say Moser has joined from Kolkata
hello pratik hi I can see Amit has
joined from Bangalore
I can see why Kumar I would love to your
name so good evening
I can see Praveen has joined from
Chennai uh so just to let you know my
name is
for this webinar and I'm joining from
Bangalore India would love to know where
you're joining from I can see Lynn has
joined from South Africa I can see Power
from vishakhapatnam
keep the introductions coming in I can
see someone from Philippines as well I
would love to your name because from
your email I am not able to understand
your name uh correct me uh and I can see
someone has joined from Kolkata as well
foreign
okay uh before we start the session uh
just to let you know that you can put
down your questions in the Q a box
surprisingly we have already started
getting questions in the Q a box uh so
that's great you have utilized your time
by joining in early but for other folks
I'm just putting down on chart here so
if you have a question related to cyber
security career or IIT kanpur's
professional certificate program which
we are going to cover in this webinar as
well uh if you have any questions
related to that so you can always go and
put down your questions in the Q a
books and we will try to take few
questions throughout the session uh but
there will be a special uh duration for
the Q a part as well so I'll make sure
your questions get answered so don't
worry about it just make sure that you
put down the questions in the Q a box uh
thank you so much
awesome I think uh we can start the
session uh so meanwhile folks are
joining it uh so uh today's session is
about career overview and how can you
become ready to become a cyber security
Maverick and also excel in your career
with IIT kanpur's professional
certificate program in cyber security so
let me take you through that but
meanwhile uh we have your ground rules
uh so you can put all your questions in
the Q a box in case you put down your
questions in the chat here uh which I
love which I'm loving like to see your
introductions here where you're joining
from but I might miss your questions
because we get a lot of messages on chat
so I would love to know what your what
query do you have related to the program
or cyber security career in general so
put only a question with the Q a box
surprisingly we have gotten a lot of
questions here already in the Q a box so
during the session if you have a
question put down the question there
I'll try to take it throughout the
session uh but in case we are able to
take those questions uh during the
session I'll take try to take it for
during the document session when we go
there towards the end of the session uh
for folks who have asked the session is
being recorded you will be getting a
recorded link to view uh um post the
webinar and also you can expect a
follow-up mail with the recording link
and also a special bonus of it uh to
request of proof of attendance for this
webinar you can provide your name in the
post webinar survey so that will help us
give you a certificate with your fully
so please do that
also we'll be talking about today's
agenda uh so obviously we'll be getting
to know more about you we'll be talking
about cyber security we'll be talking
about cyber security careers uh we'll be
talking about how the IIT conference
program gets you job ready and uh
posters that will be taking you through
the enrollment steps and also the bonus
offer which you'll be getting over mail
here and also which I talked about the Q
a part as well so we'll be having a
special duration for the Q a part uh so
just keep putting all your questions in
the Q a box and I'll make sure that uh
our speaker today Paris will joined us
uh you know uh like answers your query
and helps you with that
awesome
uh I can see folks are still giving
introductions on chat so that's great uh
would love to know uh where you're
joining from on the chat here I can see
folks have joined from Kochi Hyderabad
and ghaziabad Qatar
so awesome keep the introductions coming
in so meanwhile I would love to get to
know you a little better so uh I would
love to know like how many years of
experience do you currently have
if you can see a quick poll on your
screen uh you can see how much years of
experience do you have so I would love
to know you better in order to help you
out uh in the cyber security career
which you are aspiring to go for so I
would love to know how many years of
experience do you have so you can see
the first option uh are you currently
study uh if the second one if you have
zero to three years of experience the
third one if you have three to five
years of experience the fourth one if
you have more than five years of
experience
so you can just quickly go and vote on
the poll which you're seeing on your
screen right now because we would love
to know a little bit more about you uh
and apart from the interactions which
are great which you're giving on chat
here
uh so I can see the pores moving very
quickly uh
like the audience here is pretty
responsive we have gotten a very good
set of uh folks who have joined here uh
so yeah keep keep the introductions
coming in on chat as well if you have
already voted
and uh yeah good luck to know how many
years of experience do you have
awesome I I can see most of the folks
have already voted but few of the folks
who are left I would suggest that just
quickly go and vote uh on the poll you
see on your screen you have to vote for
the option which is more suitable for
you uh as per your experience currently
and you can just submit it
so uh folks who are applying on chat uh
just to let you know that you can just
uh
go and quickly vote for the poll okay
awesome I'll be closing the poll in uh
10 seconds
okay uh closing the poll in five seconds
so five four three two one let me in the
poll and share the result with you
you can see that uh we have gotten like
uh half of the folks who are currently
studying uh we have a few folks who have
zero to three years of experience we
have folks who have more than five years
of experience and few of them are have
three to five years of experience so
that's great thank you so much uh for uh
giving me your introduction in terms of
your experience and where you're joining
from
okay I can see the questions coming in
on chat here as well
so uh this IIT Khan post professional
certificate program in cyber security uh
it's powered by simply run uh and uh we
are known as world's number one boot
camp and also uh we are very proud to
train over 5 million plus Professionals
in over 150 plus countries also we have
been in the digital space uh for almost
uh 13 years and we are very proud of
transforming the digital skill space uh
over the year so uh welcome everyone uh
we'll be starting the session uh now
so we have our speaker here with us
Paris Arora hi Paris hey hello Russia
and thank you so much for organizing
this webinar and having me here as well
uh so just a quick introduction about me
so I have been into this industry for a
little over 19 years now I started my
journey with the hardware repair
industry where I used to work for I
would say a good it giant as of now and
we used to repair the CD-ROMs and the
hard disk and whatnot and from there the
the overall career transpired into the
I.T side of it with me taking on the
network engineering role and then the
server engineering role and whatnot and
then finally moving into a software
development end then these uh cyber
security area now after serving pretty
much into the cyber security for about
14 15 years predominantly then I moved
into Microsoft and currently I am
engaged with the Microsoft on the Azure
Cloud engineering side of it so yeah
that's pretty much about me and in this
entire journey I can say that the career
in the cyber security space has been
really eventful really exciting as well
and happy to be here as your guide as
your Mentor for the program
oh thank you so much power for your
introduction uh this just a question I'm
pretty sure the crowd also would want to
know like uh what was the turning point
of your career like how did you reach
here you know like uh a lot of people
aspired to work in Microsoft
oh yes absolutely so I can say it's uh
so if you look at any anyone's career I
think it's more about how you want to
achieve it and what you want to achieve
it so when I started off my journey I
always uh aspire to be in an elite
organization like Microsoft and the
others as well but having said so it was
a planned journey I can say the the more
you can think about it the more you can
plan now cyber security has definitely
been a part of my uh career I would say
a pretty much the major portion of my
career and while I was in the cyber
security I have worked with many
organizations including Microsoft so
there was a webinar that I delivered
with Microsoft in participation with
Microsoft and that kind of pulled me
towards it because uh the technology
that we work in Microsoft is no
different than we consume it and when I
was being interviewed for Microsoft it
was predominantly based on my site fiber
experience and also on my it experience
so it was not purely cyber but there
were different pieces which were being
put together which shaped my career
overall from an Network standpoint from
a server standpoint from software
development and from a cyber standpoint
as well so when I was interviewed for
Microsoft it was more towards the
technology understanding it was more
towards my understanding from a future
technology growth perspective and how
the current technology can shape up the
the future technology roadmap be it from
a cyber standpoint or from a non-cyber
standpoint so yeah if you are into an
organization I would say just be totally
into it understand the end-to-end
technology and that will help you in
answering some of the questions in your
interview because that will prove to the
interviewer that you know the technology
in and out so be very very thorough with
the work that you've done work no work
is small or big I think whatever you do
just do it properly and that will help
you to pave your path even forward
awesome awesome I think that's pretty
motivating inspiring so welcome Paris
again uh and thank you for a great
introduction so uh let's move on let's
talk more about cyber security uh so in
today's world cyber security has become
an essential Tool uh so Paris can you
tell us how a cyber security has become
such an essential tool in digital uh
today's digital economy
so I think that's a that's a good
question Russia so from a cyber security
standpoint see I remember my earlier
days or my childhood days we didn't had
a cell phone and we used to converse
over the uh the analog signals and the
landlines now at that point in time the
technology was not evolved so much so
that it is today now today we have the
variables in terms of the Apple watches
and the Samsung watches or the smart
gears we are using the connected cars
for example from the mg and other brands
as well so we have a technology which is
connected connected over internet now
the moment we connect over an internet
or communicate over an internet with the
server or interact there is a data that
we are sharing with the entity now these
entities can use it in the right Essence
which is for the business purposes but
at the same time if they don't put in
the relevant controls for the protection
of this data the data is out in the
public
so there is a while we talk about the
internet there is a parallel internet
which we call it as a dark web which
exists and this dark web is something
which can be accessed free of cost over
the internet and you don't have a trace
about your activities there
so you can have your aliases created
there which is not relating to your
identity and then you can interact with
the data you can sell the data you can
buy the data as well now interestingly
if you look at the car transactions so
let's say if if I am holding a credit
card it just take 10 seconds of the
interaction with an individual to steal
my card data the tools the hardware is
available on Amazon for a price tag of
12 to 14 000 so it is that cheap uh to
steal the car data if you are working
into let's say a connected if you talk
about the connected cars it is easy to
steal a car with spending just 37 to 38
000 in Indian Rupee you get a device you
clone a key of a car and then there you
go you can just unlock the car and just
walk away with it
so in today's world while the world is
moving towards much more interactions
much more intersections of the
technology the more complications it is
adding to it and irony is many
organizations they fail on the basics of
the data protection or the
infrastructure protection itself and
that's where the risk comes in
and uh I think from the today's digital
economy perspective while we are sitting
in India and talking about it the
digital economy is the reality today uh
be it a UPI transactions be it uh the
online banking transactions and whatnot
so we have also seen uh the Netflix
series jamtara where how easy it is from
a social engineering standpoint to lure
individuals into making a transaction so
yes the connected world has its own pros
and cons and we just have to be aware
and we should be ready to respond to the
cyber attacks as well
uh that's really interesting and I'm
pretty sure folks have seen that series
as well that's a very interesting series
as well uh also uh cyber security is
making the news every day as well right
uh as we can see here that uh basically
interviewers we have seen that the
Western Digital reports network security
incident which happened right uh so can
you tell us about the cyber security
which is making news every day as well a
little bit about that yeah so I think
you have captured the interesting ones
on the screen so the first one is the
oaklands and some blues now this one is
uh is a Cyber attack that happened in
the Feb 2023 this year basically and the
attack was carried out by a group called
play now this group is pretty new into
the cyber security which was kind of
emerged in 2022 which is last year the
attackers they exploited a vulnerability
in the Microsoft Exchange Server named
as proxy not shell which was a zero day
wallet ability which was also
acknowledged by Microsoft so they
exploited the vulnerability in Microsoft
Exchange they infiltrated the
environment and they encrypted the
cities which is the Oklahoma or Auckland
cities computer systems
uh they demanded or Ransom but Oakland
refused to pay the The Ransom back to
the attackers uh they so the attackers
were able to compromise and stole some
data from the city and leaked it on the
dark web that we just talked about
exposing the personal information of
thousands of current and the former city
employees and the residents of Auckland
now which essentially means that anyone
who has worked for or interacted with
the city of Auckland
was compromised now what was compromised
was the social security numbers driver
license numbers birth dates home
addresses police misconduct allegations
bank statements and also some of the
private information on the current and
past City Mayors of the city now
this information if I put in myself into
those shoes or that particular situation
I would obviously be furious about it
and would be worried about my data as
well like I don't want everybody to know
my house address or my mobile number or
my social security number which is as
good as aadhaar in India so
I don't want to I don't want a public at
Mars to know about it right and the FBI
there is still investigating the
incident they are trying to recover from
the damage uh the ransomware attack has
definitely caused a lot of frustration
and anxiety for the people affected by
it so yeah it was one of the notable
breaches that happened uh from a cyber
standpoint this year the second one
which we see on the screen is on the
Western Digital reports uh on the
network security incident now this one
is a classic example where the third
party which was in partnership with
Western Digital they had access to the
Western Digital systems as well from the
maintenance from the user Administration
and the server Administration
perspective so they got breached by a
phishing attack now this phishing attack
is is a type of attack where
an attacker sends out an email
believing or you know kind of imposing
it to be let's say coming from a bank or
from Amazon or from any other retail
store and so on and if I have an account
on that particular platform it the email
would just really click here to gain
back your access or there is a
transaction which is pending your
authorization
or the account is going to be inactive
if you do not activate today so this
these kind of statements basically
enable or Force an individual to log on
to click onto the link first of all and
then put in their credentials onto the
forged web page now the moment they do
it the credentials are compromised so in
this particular attack as well
the attackers send out a phishing email
to a third party of Western Digital and
uh then the credentials were compromised
they were able to log into the Western
Digital Network they affected the
overall cloud storage of Western Digital
and took about 10 terabytes of data the
code signing certificate private phone
numbers of executive lot of back office
data and they also were able to capture
on the Microsoft Azure tenant
so essentially they were just
controlling the organization completely
yeah so this is something which a third
party vendor uh you know the Western
Digital is dependent on the third party
vendor to make sure that the controls
are in place and uh the third party
vendor is taking good care of it
the third one which is uh Putin's Global
cyber warfare tactics I think this is
this is the one which is related to the
Ukraine war as well uh
obviously this is a political in nature
and what happened in this is uh we
there's a leak which prescribed that
there is a organization called NTC
Vulcan which was working with the
Russian military intelligence agencies
and they were supporting the hacking
operations spreading the disinformation
about the Ukraine war and were also part
of controlling the internet to some
extent
now the NTC Vulcan was also linked to
the the notorious hacking groups like
sandworm which was responsible for
several cyber attacks on Ukraine South
Korea South Korea and other countries as
well
what this uh the files that were kind of
released on the dark web
suggested that uh there were so there's
a lot of manuals and reports which were
there which suggested the use and the
deployment of software systems such as
msatv scanvi and Crystal to we which
were designed to manipulate the online
Communications scan and exploit the
vulnerabilities and also to train cyber
operators respectively
which means they were building up a
force or a cyber Army the second thing
was uh that that got compromised in hair
or were revealed that there was software
specification sheets the source code
Snippets for some of the software
systems which shows their features
functions and technical details which
means that there is a software system
which was compromised from a blueprint
perspective and the vulnerabilities can
be identified in those blueprints so
yeah I mean these kind of details were
lead and which suggested that the Russia
did had an opportunity to attack on
Ukraine and other Asian countries like
South Korea to kind of manipulate their
their ID systems and their citizens data
as well
so yeah I think these were some of the
notable security incidents the other one
uh which I just want to talk about is on
the ransomware attack that happened in
May which is very recent I would say on
the uh United States states so there was
a colonial pipeline that was there in
the United States east coast and the
ransomware attack happened there in the
month of May 23 which disrupted the fuel
supplies all along the east coast
the attack was carried out by the hacker
group called Dark Side they demanded
about 4.4 million dollars in Bitcoin as
a ransom and it also this particular
attack basically exposed the
vulnerability of critical infrastructure
to cyber threats and cause Panic buying
and prices uh got high for the gasoline
so so yeah Cyber attack is not only to
an individual or to an organization but
can also be affecting the states and the
citizen uh think about a situation the
the fuel price is going up because of a
Cyber attack and the price is getting
manipulated so yeah uh these kind of uh
this is the real reality from an uh
cyber security perspective that we live
in today
well that's that's really interesting
and scary as well at the same time uh
thank you so much Paris for seeing it
take us through that I can see one
question uh from uh the chat here by
Kieran that my question is what is the
biggest challenge cyber security domain
is facing nowadays see I think from a
cyber security domain perspective there
are multiple challenges but I think the
top most is of the talent itself
I have been into this industry for for
long I have talked about it and being
into this industry I can say very
confidently that even today we do not
have let's say the Auditors I mean if I
talk about one particular profession so
we do not have the Auditors having an
understanding of the IIT system we do
not have the pen testers knowing what
they are doing or what tool they are
they are running and what impact it can
cause to the Target system
thirdly we do not have the red team
testers or the penetration testers to
not only test the ITA systems but also
the human element of it which is linked
to the social engineering and I think
the bigger issue is overall
understanding of the cyber security
domain in itself for some it is just a
tick in the Box exercise for some it is
about running tool without knowing the
tool and for some it is about running
the tool but didn't they do not
understand the outcome of the tool so
yeah I think the biggest challenge today
is on the talent itself and that's
something which I think has been
addressed by a lot of uh I would say
news agencies a lot of surveys lot of
independent research organizations as
well and time and again this is the need
of an R which is still unfulfilled I
would say
until to that I hope that answers your
question
thank you for the answer guys uh so
let's move on and uh so what exactly are
the leaders saying about cyber security
today so uh you can see that Stephanie
and apple uh it takes 20 years to build
a reputation and few minutes of cyber
incident to ruin it uh and you can see
Robert who's the former director of the
FBI says that there are only two types
of companies uh those uh that have been
hacked and those that will be had uh and
uh I can see uh in the khatri uh from
Deep AI if our computer is not safe then
we are also not safe mentally and
socially let's secure our computers to
be safe uh what do you say about this
I think uh the the Roberts uh the uh
saying is kind of that I have used
throughout my life as well on my
presentations because I truly believe
into it and uh the reason I say so is
there was a security incident which I
was part of I was investigating I was
part of the forensics team and there was
a breach that happened the organization
in Pune
in about 2013 year and uh when I was
part of that team what we realized was
the attackers were part of the system
for about seven to eight months and the
organization did not had any clue about
it
so they were operating as normal the
attackers were learning out the system
they were learning out the Integrations
of the system from Oracle database to
the tomcat and whatnot and then
eventually one day they planned a time
bomb uh kind of a software where
everything would trigger in a matter of
seconds and they were able to siphon off
45 million dollars in a span of seconds
across 18 countries so I mean think
about a magnitude of an impact 18
transactions happening at the same time
in different countries from A same
credit card siphoning off about 45
million dollars so so yeah that was one
of the incidents and then uh if even if
I look at the Consulting organizations
or let's talk about Microsoft uh so in
Microsoft as well in recent times itself
we have seen the attacks being targeted
towards it uh while the Microsoft is
definitely one of the leaders into
technology area but still is not uh
immune to the cyber attacks so if
Microsoft cannot be an immune to a Cyber
attack I can confidently say that none
of the organization today is immune to
it and whatever controls that we put in
it's at the end it's a software that we
are running to protect ourselves and the
softwares would come with their own
vulnerabilities would come with their
own weakness and limitation and that's
something which the attackers are always
exploiting and taking uh the lead lead
there and
I was watching a web series again a
family man where it says it just takes
uh one effort or one instance for an
attacker to lead or to win but whereas
uh if we are into a kind of a respondent
or a Defender then it takes all those
events or all those instances for us to
protect the organization again so so
yeah it's a tough job being into cyber
security it's exciting but yeah I truly
resonate with all these uh sayings that
you have put on the slide Russia
awesome thank you so much Paris uh also
as the cyber security crimes are growing
the cyber security growth is also
facilitating you know towards it can you
tell us more about it
yeah for sure so I think uh from a cyber
security growth perspective I remember
when this entire cyber security buzzword
started so initially it was information
security and uh the way it was
structured was more towards the
compliances so if I'm into a particular
industry I would have a certain
compliances to follow and for that
particular thing there was a department
that got formed named as information
security because it was everything about
information then the era changes and the
buzzword came out with the cyber
security which is more towards the
connected world
so it is no more only revolving around
information but rather it is more about
Connections it is more about the
intersections that we do and uh this
industry I have seen being Grew From
about let's say if I talk about a
particular Department uh initially if it
was about four individuals in the
department today it is 40. uh and I'm
just talking about like seven years back
or eight years back for a very very
small firm if I talk about the mid-size
organizations the role has evolved into
different departments itself like a pen
testing would be one Department uh code
testing would be another department the
compliances would be another department
the risk would be another department and
all the department would have a decent
number of requirement from a job
positioning standpoint uh if I talk
about the large organizations the roles
are even more in demand
uh so if I talk about Microsoft it is
not only for the organization but also
the support that we provide to our
customers
so you have a security support
department on each of the product you
have a in-house support team for the
security incidents and then you have a
compliances team and then you have the
Privacy team so so I think the the roles
are definitely evolving uh similar to
Wade if I look into the tooling side of
it uh initially it was about log core
relation so the First Market started
with the log collection then it moved
into a log correlation then today we are
talking about the edrs we are talking
about the behavioral analysis and now in
the coming time we are going to talk
about the AI or the artificial
intelligence as well so yes the market
is definitely on a growth path
even today if if we search on the job
portals I think cyber security leads the
open positions in the market and that's
something which is driving the market as
well and like you have put it on the
slide as well it's about the cyber
security jobs uh which is uh available
versus the vague which is there in the
market as well
so yes it is on a growth Trend and I
have seen this growth Trend since 2010
every single day the growth is there
it's just that we are unable to fulfill
the growth
oh well that's interesting thank you so
much Paris was teaching us through the
cyber security growth uh also now we'll
be talking about careers in cyber
security meanwhile uh just to let you
know that we are getting a lot of
interesting questions in the Q a box
we'll be taking those questions have
some patience uh and uh we'll be talking
about how does cyber security play a
vital role in our businesses and
personal lives
I saw an interesting question on the
chart related to this that why are
Indian hackers uh considered as
criminals
yeah
I think
um
I would say it uh it is a so I would not
say that we are criminals first of all
uh there's there's a multi-faced this is
a multi-phase uh discipline so if I talk
about the cyber security there are two
parts of it one is definitely the bad
guys which we call it as a hacker or an
attackers and again we are being we are
judging them here by calling them as a
bad guy then there is a sign there's a
kind of individuals who are always into
a protecting mode and we call them as a
Defenders or the organization security
teams and whatnot now the moment we talk
about the attackers or the hackers
we always think about the bad bad guys
there are bad guys right but but whether
they are bad or not it's totally being
determined by the motivation or the
outcome that they want to drive
sometimes the attackers or the hackers
can be a state sponsored as well for
example if today India think about
building a cyber security army or a
hackers Army we would not call them as a
bad guys we would call them as the army
of attackers so a we should not judge
them whether it is legal or illegal that
is up to a court to decide upon but
I was uh reading a very interesting
article yesterday uh from Z wherein
there will be they were very proud of
certain individuals specifically the
youngsters the way we are performing
into the Olympics and they were also
comparing the Indian hackers to say we
are proud of you right so it's just
about how we perceive them uh we are I I
can say we are very capable from a cyber
security standpoint considering the
wealth of knowledge that we have
considering the contribution of the
cyberspace that the India contributes to
I think we are very very well placed uh
the most notable country I would say
which is considered bad from the
cyberspace perspective is China uh but
again we should not judge them because
not all the apples are same so again the
motivations can be different and it
totally depends on the intent of the
individual it can be from anywhere of
any any individual from any part of the
world so I would say it's uh it's very
judgmental by being that we are bad or
not but I think from an India standpoint
we are doing fantabulously well from a
cyber security standpoint
awesome I hope that answers your
question as well from the chat
uh now moving on to the job growth part
as well uh so what folks can inter uh
basically it's in interest in terms of
what kind of Rose they can take up or
you know what kind of job growth they
can expect in the coming years
so I was reading through one of the
questions itself uh on the chat where
one of the participants I think have
asked I am from a non-it and can I take
up the Journey of cyber security and I
think the answer is yes
and why I say so is see it is just the
technology that you can leverage to
achieve certain tasks now cyber security
is just an extension of that ID
obviously the efforts that you need to
put in would be slightly more than a
person knowing the ID so anybody can
take up the cyber security role it's
just that you have to be very very clear
in terms of what you are what you want
to achieve so there are multiple streams
in cyber security itself so one is
related to an antivirus so you for
example so you can be a researcher in an
antivirus organization where you are
working on the malwares on the exploits
identification of it you can be a
freelancer as well where you are
creating the malware so you are
Developer and you want to start your
career into cyber security so you can
start developing the malwares for
exploitation of the vulnerabilities
contribute that to an antivirus
organization so that they can prepare a
vaccine for it as well so that if today
you are able to create a malware there
could be another person who will be able
to create or replicate that so you
should have a vaccine for it so
antivirus organizations hire a lot of
malware experts or the researchers
the second kind of role that you can
look at from a technology standpoint
only if I talk about so you can be a red
team expert you can be a penetration
tester you can be a vulnerability
researcher and these all streams are
more towards the technology so these are
technology oriented streams then there
is a stream where you do not have
the dependency on ID to a great extent
so you can read if you are able so let's
say you are into a legal profession you
can take up a Cyber Law as a steam for
you you can take up the compliances as a
stream for you you can take up the
opportunity from the Privacy standpoint
I mean these these are some of the
buzzwords which are being used today uh
privacy is is on the top of the uh
discussions even for the boards as well
so you can be a privacy expert if you
want a non-it related uh stream you can
be a risk expert if you are very good in
calculations you are mathematically very
strong so you can take up a risk
assessor or a risk management kind of a
role where you are qualifying or
quantifying the risk and then coming up
with with the formulas to to say the
particular activity is so risky and so
on so you can be a threat researcher and
and whatnot so I think there are
multiple streams uh which an individual
can take it up if a person is into a
server or a network and they want to
take up a cyber security uh as a job or
a career growth
they can definitely uh get into a sock
operation they can they they can go in
for a server security or the server
Administration part as well they can
participate in the identity and access
management from a security standpoint so
yes for every stream there is a
possibility and opportunity inside
so awesome uh thank you so much Paris
for explaining that uh also uh as you
can see that there are many many roles
you know which people folks can take up
in cyber security uh like what are the
cyber security skills uh which will play
a very important role in terms of taking
up uh you know uh these uh many cyber
security roles as a beginner as well as
an experienced person as well
so these roles I can just say is just a
10 to 20 of the roles uh which are
available in the market so from a
security infrastructure specialist
perspective if somebody has a network or
a server background from an
Administration perspective they can take
up this particular role Network Security
Consultants are highly in demand so
anybody who is coming up with the
network background they can opt in for
this particular role security analyst is
another role which is very much in
demand from a Consulting organization
and from the industry itself so anybody
who is coming from a software background
they would do very well in the
application security related uh actions
or these themes like malware analyst or
the application security analyst so they
would do really well in these streams
somebody who is from an infra background
they would do good in Cloud security as
well and and specifically from an
architect standpoint point if if there's
an individual who has a good
understanding of network plus server
plus the end point which is uh end user
system they would do absolutely well in
the cyber security architect role and
that's the role which is
I would say it's emerging role and a lot
of organization a lot of Enterprises are
looking up for these individuals to be
available in the market there's a
certification as well from the cloud
providers wherein the individuals can go
and opt-in for these roles as a path so
yes the roles are very much in demand
from a blue team member red team members
as well uh it's more about how you are
enticing an individual into doing
certain thing it can be a social
engineering role as well it can be a
technology-oriented role as well so all
of these roles I would say is just about
10 to 20 of the rules which are
available in the market Auditors are
very much in demand for example today
uh wherein we as an industry we need
good individuals to look into the
systems and then come up with their
findings which can be fixed uh why we
want to get them fixed so that the bad
guys doesn't get them to it so so yes uh
Auditors are very much in demand
identity and access management
administrators are very much in demand
uh there are a lot of organizations
which work only on the integration piece
of it from technology to technology from
authentication authorization standpoint
and these individuals would help in
filling up those those gaps as well
awesome uh like we are getting a
question on the chart here how good this
course will be for physical security
expert versus a basically
uh maybe can you differentiate on the
basically the titles the physical
security expert was a cyber security
expert
so so I would say cyber security is
incomplete with the physical security
without looking at a physical security
rather
and the reason I say so is
uh so we did an exercise for one of the
reputed banks in Mumbai where the task
was to breach into the data center
without the authorization without the ID
cards without the permissions so we kind
of faked our identities uh we created
the fake batches we went inside we were
able to penetrate the data center
physical security layer by giving them a
comfort that we are indeed from an audit
department they agreed to it we went
inside we had physical Hardware USB
drives with us which we planted onto
these servers there was a network man in
the middle tool as well that we had we
planted that as well with a logo on top
of it that do not touch it is a system
sensitive stuff and the uh the the
downside of it was we were able to get a
lot of data from the banking systems
which we submitted back to the
organization as a proof of concept
and yes so physical security is required
for the cyber security but whether it is
needed for all these roles the answer is
no
so for example if I talk about the
network security concerned and our
security infrastructure specialist
application security analyst so these
roles are focusing towards a particular
stream of the testing or a particular
stream of cyber security
cyber security in itself is a universe
today right so so we are not talking
about the complete Universe rather we
are preparing you from this course in
terms of knowing what essentially are
the different streams and what are the
foundational skills you would need to
grow into a career you can't imagine to
learn everything in a six months time
period there is there's a lot of stuff
which gets integrated into cyber
security but with this particular course
you would be learning most of the stuff
if not all
uh now let's go to the main part of
actually doing this course we've been
even becoming a cyber security expert
the salary part uh so uh as we can see
the Indian average annual salaries for a
cyber security engineer is starting from
minimum four lakh by RM to 12 and a
cyber security architect earns up to 42
lakhs per annum uh and uh CSO expert
actually earns 61 lives when Anna and so
on uh we have gotten this details from
uh you know uh the source from Glassdoor
but uh do you have a comment on the
salary part because I think that is also
one important part why would anyone want
to become a cyber security expert as it
is a growing field as well right in
terms of career so can you tell us
something about it I would say Russia
these are very very conservative numbers
uh from uh cyber security engineer
perspective itself I can tell you the
maximum is the minimum today
for cyber security architect the maximum
is probably in the average range today
and for a c show again the maximum is in
the average range today so so I would
say the the ranges have grown
tremendously well I know our Cesar who
owns four crores a year
and I know very dear friend of mine who
earns about 85 lakh rupees a year and
he's a fresh see so just got into a
seesaw role so so yeah the numbers are
very very conservative
for cyber architect or a cyber security
architect I can I can say the uh the
average would be somewhere around 50 to
60 and the maximum there is no end to it
for cyber security engineer the minimum
would be to relax as a starting uh again
though it depends on organization to
organization as well but I'm just
talking or generalizing it uh the
maximum for a cyber security engineer I
know individuals into this particular
role and it would go up to 40 to 50
lakhs as well so so yes the the roles
are evolving and the so as the salaries
wow that's pretty motivating for folks
who are looking actually forward to you
know go into this field so that's really
amazing also uh Paris can you elaborate
on the range of career options that an
individual can take up pursue within
this Dynamic field of service security
so Russia like I said there are multiple
streams so one can be a non-id related
wherein the individual from a law
background or from a non-it background
they can pursue a career into compliance
uh it can be ISO 27001 uh system auditor
it can be an ISO 27001 implementer as
well similarly the person can contribute
towards the risk identification the risk
assessment team they can be part of the
risk management team overall in an
organization uh so these are the roles
which are available for the non-id they
can be part of the Privacy team as well
for a technology-oriented roles uh like
network security vulnerability
assessment then digital forensics
Incident Management
data data management and identity
management these are some of the roles
which are more suited towards the
technology
but for non-technology like business
continuity uh can be a best suited role
which is also one of the important
aspects for any organization to sustain
uh the business continuity role is very
much in demand not only in India but
also abroad uh similarly asset and
inventory management does not require
too much of I.T understanding so people
can take up this role because this is a
foundation for any of the technology uh
framework to rely upon or data privacy
can be taken up by the non-id
individuals so yes there can be ID
oriented roles there can be non-id
oriented roles it's just totally depend
on the individuals and Trust where they
want test from their time perspective
oh thank you so much for answering that
Paris uh we are getting a lot of
questions late to the basically uh the
career paths they can take maybe they
can take it in the Q a part uh so moving
on
um there are many tools libraries
platforms you know which folks will get
to uh you know learn in this particular
program of IIT Conquest professional
certificate program and cyber security
uh Paris can you maybe tell us a little
bit about these tools
I think we are getting one question on
the Q a box as well maybe once you're
done we will take that question related
tools as well sure so I think of these
all tools the uh the mother of all tool
is Kali Linux and uh it has got so first
of all it is available as a community
Edition so you can download use the Tool
uh or an operating system in itself
but having said so all these tools are
the specialized tools which have been in
the industry for long and they perform a
very very specific task for the uh
for the pen testers I would say wherein
they will be able to determine the
vulnerabilities so there's a complete
cycle if I have to talk about it so
there's a complete cycle of uh Cyber
attack so it starts from a
reconnaissance so for reconnaissance I
can use Wireshark I can use nmap pen
test tools uh MX toolbox so these are
the tools which will help me in
identifying my Target and profiling my
target
then moving on from a reconnaissance it
goes up to creating the weapon uh so
weaponization is a second stage where I
can use Kali Linux there's there's a
tool called
MSX uh this
oh Bob food for example which is on the
screen so we can use that we can use msf
Venom or the so this msf Venom can
create a malware for me on Kali Linux
platform I can use msf console as the
another tool which can help me in
launching an exploit so my weaponization
stage moves to the exploitation stage
where based on the vulnerabilities that
I have determined I am basically
exploiting the vulnerabilities by the
weapon that I have created now before
the exploitation happen I need to
deliver the weapon to the uh to the
Target or to the victim as well and
that's where Kali Linux has a tool
called social engineering platform or
the social engineering tool which helped
me in creating a phishing page or a
phishing website on the Fly
so
Metasploit is the msf console or the msf
Venom that I talked about so so once I
have delivered the weapon I exploit that
particular weapon on the targets victim
machine and after the exploitation I
gain access
once I gain access I take actions on the
target I clear off my tracks and then I
take or exfiltrate the data uh to my
machine so this is the entire stage and
these are the tools which will depict
those entire stages for us uh Wireshark
help us in doing a TCP level or a
protocol level analysis while the Google
Doc is more of a passive scanning where
without being available without leaving
my traces into the target system I can
find out the information about the
target verbs would help me in
identifying the vulnerabilities on the
application be it a mobile or a web nmap
help me in doing an active profiling of
the tool so as the edge being TCP Dam or
the Lippy cap help me in exploiting a
vulnerability let's say on the on the
wireless interface or on the ethernet
interface as well so
all of these tools are helpful when you
are doing a penetration testing these
are some basic tools which you would
need at any point in time to either
perform a vulnerability assessment or to
uh do a pen testing exercise
uh awesome uh that sounds pretty
interesting uh I just want to quickly
read a question related to this I think
you may have already answered it uh so
this is from chatra uh from the Q a box
so I can see this question how safe are
the red team tools to run in a
non-sandbox environment what is the
legal framework around the usage of
tools Linux Kali is with scary to run
sure so I would say uh your question is
very spot on uh from the context
standpoint uh if you look at Kali Linux
there is a hosted machine which you get
on the Microsoft Azure on AWS on Google
Cloud as well so there is a environment
which is tested for the binaries which
are posted on the Kali Linux
if you are downloading or using any tool
which you are not confident upon my
suggestion is do not use it on the
production environment use only it into
a sanitized environment or a Sandbox
environment now while running it it is
always preferable to have one system
dedicated towards these tools and once
you are done with your exercise just
reformat re-image the machine and get it
afresh for the next site next set of
your testing
there was a time when my team was
developing a particular tool on Ruby on
Rails language
and they were downloading certain
modules from the internet for the tool
to work and later on when we tested the
developed outcome we realized that there
were certain transactions which were
going to non-india servers as well which
was not our server and the transactions
were going to some other server and
that's where we realized that it is not
safe to download and use even the
modules when you are developing
a software so I think it's it's best to
use the tools that you are downloading
from internet into a very very safe
environment test them out thoroughly and
then use it onto your testing machine
which should be separate from a
production machine test it down or use
it on the testing machine and once the
testing is done then get the testing
machine re-image that's the best option
available
uh that sounds interesting uh I hope
chitra
[Music]
uh so now uh so we have talked about the
skills and we have talked about the
career paths we have talked about
basically what us uh basically what
salaries will be getting uh Paris has
given a very detailed explanation of the
salary part which is very important so
you can see a quick call on your screen
in order to help you out better I would
love to know that what exactly is
stopping you from taking this cyber
security certification so this is a
multiple choice question you can select
multiple options so as you can see a
very quick pull on your screen uh that I
can find a fully comprehensive
curriculum uh if that is your concern
you can choose that one you can see a
second option of I don't have the
Practical exposure I need to become job
ready and the third one I find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos uh and the last one is my work
schedule wouldn't allow me enough time
for learning so uh please let us know
your biggest concern what is stopping
you from taking the cyber security
certification
and meanwhile you're doing that I can
see the pores moving in we've gotten so
many interesting questions in the Q a
box and we cannot wait to take those up
as well so uh just a few minutes away
from the Q a part so uh stay tuned and
uh yeah uh loving loving the interaction
on the chat here folks like I can see
that people are very curious about the
cyber security uh in general you know
knowing about it
yeah
so I'll be closing the poll in 15
seconds if we have the folks who have
not voted in uh you can just go and uh
quickly vote basically what is the
biggest concern you have you know when
you think about taking up cyber security
as a career option and uh also uh as we
are talking about IET Concourse uh this
professional certificate course in cyber
security if you have a concern related
to that as well you know you can also uh
fill in uh this uh poll here quick poll
here and uh here you can choose multiple
options as well in case uh you are not
satisfied only with one concern so yeah
I can say most of the folks have already
voted we have gotten a very active
interactive audience here
yes indeed I would I would conquer with
that Russia
so I'll give like 10 seconds more for
few of the folks who have not voted so
what exactly is stopping you from taking
up the cyber security certification
taking from the side of security career
path uh so you can see those quick four
options on your screen uh so I'll close
the poll in 10 seconds
foreign
you can just quickly go and submit the
concern you have so based on that we'll
get an understanding what is your
biggest concern when it comes to cyber
security as a career in
awesome I can see all of the folks have
almost voted only fewer left so I'll be
closing the poll in five seconds
so five four
three two one so let me end the poll and
share the results as well
okay uh okay we can see Paris the
biggest concern here is that I can't
find a program with a fully
comprehensive curriculum uh being the
biggest concern here and the second one
is that I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready and
few of them has said that I find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded
videos and uh my work schedule wouldn't
allow enough time for learning so now uh
let's talk about the IIT campus
professional certificate program and
service security right team uh so this
course actually provides you a
comprehensive and Industry aligned
learning path uh you get access to
integrated and Hands-On labs and
projects which we'll be talking about
you know moving on like much more detail
about that and you get access to live
virtual classrooms where you can easily
learn from which uh the learning
platform is available 24 7 for you to
access and also folks who wouldn't find
time uh you know this program is
actually very flexible and it will fit
in your schedule perfectly so this
program is of six months duration and
all you need to do is you need to give
only 10 to 15 hours per week in order to
complete this professional certificate
uh program in cyber security written by
IIT carport uh Paris I just want to know
like what level of productivity uh a
person should put in in order to uh
become a cyber security expert an
example like you know completing a
program in six months so what level of
productivity uh would you suggest to you
know keep up with uh basically learning
more about cyber security because
because it will be a completely new
thing right for folks who are joining
this program
so Mr Russia I think for people who are
new to cyber security uh they should
really
consider this as a upsc exam wherein
they would have to put in a lot of
efforts a lot of time in understanding
first of all the concepts about it uh so
people who are non-id and new to cyber
security I'm talking about them so they
should really look at investing about
six to seven hours on a daily basis
people who are into ID they are working
or they have an understanding of an IDE
they can put about two hours on a daily
basis
which makes about uh 14 to 15 hours
let's say a week
for individuals who are proficient in ID
who are already working into an ID field
for long
they can put about let's say an R
per day into this program which makes
about seven to eight hours so yeah
ranging between seven to seven hours to
16 hours for people who are aware about
ID and who are experienced into ID but
for people who are non-it they would
have to put in a little more effort I
would say about at minimum four hours
per day
uh so yeah yeah thing about
electricity and liability for this
program you need to have a basic
understanding of programming and cyber
security uh which Paris has already
mentioned you know that you can come
from a non-programming background but
having a very basic knowledge I would
help you need to have a bachelor's
degree in a related field with 50 or
higher marks and you don't have to have
a work experience you know in order to
basically take up this program so these
are the eligibility and criterias
now uh like we'll be talking about how
exactly this program builds your cyber
security skills step by step and gets
your job ready uh Paris can you take us
through the uh steps of uh basically how
the cyber security skills you know go uh
hand in hand when taken through the
steps yeah okay so so I think the first
and the foremost stepping stone is about
gaining an understanding of the entire
process understanding what the cyber
security in reality is so whether it's a
uh it's so first of all we should get it
very clear that after completing this
particular course we are not going to be
a proficient hacker
okay we will be working on the ethical
side of it while there would be certain
Elements which can be leveraged or used
for the non-ethical purposes as well but
in this entire curriculum since we would
be reading about or learning about the
tools and the techniques which can go
both ways if you would predominantly
focus on the ethical side of it so the
orientation session the ethical hacking
being the first foundational stepping
stones for us would allow us to
understand what the ethics in reality
means how to undertake a particular
testing engagement with an organization
what is a document called Rules of
Engagement what are The Binding ethics
from a penetration testing standpoint or
from a technology testing standpoint
further to that we will we would be
taking on the tools we would be learning
the tools and we would be carrying out
the vulnerability assessment which would
allow us to identify the vulnerabilities
on a scale of low to catastrophic so we
would be able to determine and
appreciate those vulnerabilities from
the availability in the environment
perspective so we would know about the
vulnerabilities in an application
vulnerabilities and I.T systems
vulnerability in networking systems and
so on
once we have identified the
vulnerability then we have to categorize
those vulnerability into buckets and we
have to exploit those vulnerabilities
the exploitation part is something which
would be covered under the penetration
testing stage where we would be
evaluating the vulnerability validating
those vulnerabilities and the impact the
exploitation of those vulnerabilities
can carry on the overall infrastructure
further to this there would be a
Capstone project which will be more of a
hands-on experience for the individual
and that will prove your participation
in the program that will prove your uh I
would say the efforts that you have put
in from a learning standpoint which
would be more of an outcome based
project which would be evaluated and
then it kind of
completes the program overall
um well that's awesome thank you so much
Paris for taking us through the steps
and also talking about the electives so
the elective here uh are optional and we
do not charge anything extra for that so
it comes as a part of the program so
it's optional like if you want you can
take it up you have full support from
our end and now uh talking about the
work uh basically you get to work on the
real uh business implications projects
which you can work on as you can see on
the screen uh you get to gain access to
a victim's machine you get to work on a
bank application on vapt and you also
get vulnerability assessment and
exploitation and many more uh just had a
question that how does working on real
business implicated projects helps you
boost your CV as well you know when
you're going and applying for jobs uh
you obviously don't come from this
background like let's assume and uh
working on projects uh in real time how
does this help you know when you are
completed the certification and we're
out there you know applying for jobs and
they are asking for an experience but uh
these projects can boost
in a certain way right
so that's how I got my first job in
cyber security so uh when I was looking
out for a job in cyber I was a developer
at that time and I was fascinated by
this particular role of cyber security
being into the audit side of it so I
read through an NISD publication on the
risk management that was something that
I still remember by her and that was the
first document that I read on Cyber in
my entire life
and uh what I did was based on the
softwares that I was developing in the
organization or the tools that I was
working on I started to apply that nist
approach onto my life projects
how that helped me is I was able to
identify the bugs in my project first of
all which resulted in the elevated or a
better experience to my customer at that
point in time I was able to give or
provide a bug free product or a secure
product to my customers
so that so A it helped me in that
particular field secondly since I have
applied the nist approach onto the
developed application
that is something that goes into my
blood now so when I approached an
organization for an interview uh they
were asking about the nist thankfully
and uh I was since it was by heart to me
and I had applied that particular
approach I was able to explain the
entire process to the interviewer at
that time and the interview ran for
about two two and a half hours in 2007
or 2006 rather so interview carried
about for two two and a half hours and
the questions were were more about the
security into software development and
considering the application of that
framework into my real world examples or
the real world work I was able to answer
those questions so yes working on the
real business
applications a bit uh gaining access to
the victims machine which is very much
happening even today uh vapt on a
banking application it is a need both
from a compliance standpoint and from a
risk standpoint these are certain
projects which are undertaken by the
bank every year and not rather every
year but rather every quarter and after
any software upgrade or a change on the
banking application as well so that's a
real problem or a real need today as
well vulnerability assessment and the
exploitation again this is something
which is a part of compliances so if you
talk about ISO 27001 if we talk about
the PCI DSS if we talk about the irda
compliances or the RBI compliances VA
vulnerability assessment and the
penetration testing is the need for most
of the organizations today even a
startup today when they launch a product
they can't launch a product without the
VA and the PT done and without fixing
the security vulnerabilities
most of us would would be using the your
smartphones and every month every
quarter every six months we do receive
an update from the oems talking about
the security vulnerabilities and the
fixes to it and these are just an
outcomes of those vulnerability
assessments the code testing and stuff
so so yeah these are all the all the
real examples uh that we have taken and
these would help you and enable you to
visualize the entire cycle and uh would
be able to convince the interviewer as
well in terms of the efforts and the
reality and the practicality of it when
it comes to you doing it by your hand so
yes these are very very relevant
wow that's interesting thank you so much
also we also have a caption
caption blinds as well uh like like
could you tell us something about a
caption project like to have it in a
resume how does it help
so it does help because Capstone
projects are usually
the large projects so these are not
creation of a script so these projects
are not creation of a script these are
not about writing a white paper these
are about identifying the problem and
then applying your entire learning into
creating something which is realistic
which can be consumed by the industry so
you would have to apply your learnings
from the security perspective defenses
perspective more so so that you create
something unique as a concept or as a
working pilot or as a prototype which
can be consumed by an organization as a
as a beta testing product and then
eventually the industry can grow on top
of it
the benefit that you get is basically a
Hands-On learning you would be working
on a real world business requirements
and the problems and since it's a real
world it will be much more adaptable by
the organizations uh much more faster so
so these are some of or rather the
Capstone project would be one experience
which you typically get in the programs
like mtech and so on so at that
particular stature you get the
experience of working on the Capstone
project that you will be getting in this
particular uh engagement or this
curriculum as well
uh well that's great and also we have a
simply run community that supports you
so uh as a learner you will be getting
access to instructors program manager
cohort manager learning teams and peer
which the environment of learning will
be very uh you know friendly and Lively
and also you'll be getting access to
curriculum resources through the simple
community so you can always go and ask
your query there and the trainers will
be helping you out with the solution and
also I can see that folks have asked
questions that do you get a job after
you know completing the certification so
we do provide job assist Services by IM
jobs we have partnered with them uh in
this particular service you can access
to job total and also you get a resume
review and rewrite Services uh and
also one-on-one interview Service as
well once you've completed the
certification
foreign
so yeah so I would love to know that are
you interested in enrolling in this
program so if you can see on your screen
right now uh there's a quick poll uh So
based on your interest uh would you like
to enroll in this IIT campus
professional certificate program in
cyber security red team so you can see a
quick poll on the screen here uh so
folks who are interested in enrolling
the program we would love to know uh to
help you out better and take you through
the program in much more detail uh so
you can see a quick poll on your screen
here so would you like to enroll in this
program so you can just uh quickly just
choose an option if you're interested in
the program you can just choose the
option yes and submit it
so I'll just leave this poll uh for some
time meanwhile just check we have gotten
a lot of interesting questions in the Q
a which will be taking up just after
this pretty soon so yeah looking forward
to this one
because during the session as well we're
getting a lot of interesting questions
uh so yeah
so meanwhile folks who have already
voted yes uh if you've submitted your
answer here on the poll you can go on
the Q a box and please do raise your
question related to the program if you
have if you have a very specific
question related to cyber security
career uh you can ask Paris and uh get
your query answer so yeah I'll make sure
that your question gets through uh so
make sure it's available it's related to
cyber security that's all so yeah so
I'll be closing the poll in uh 10
seconds I can see most of the folks have
already chosen I can see a lot of
interest here towards the program so
that's that's really uh interesting so
I'll be closing the poll in 10 seconds
so would you like to enroll in this
program you can see a quick poll on your
screen
awesome uh so I'll be closing the poll
in five seconds uh last five seconds to
vote so five four three two one so let
me end the poll and uh we can see that
almost like seventy percent of folks are
interested in enrolling the program so
that's great now uh let's move on to the
uh how basically you can enroll for this
program uh again I can see like folks
have asked on the chat here as well that
you know what are the steps what is the
fee structure so let me take you through
that as well so uh there are very simple
basic steps you can follow to enroll in
this program you can submit an
application uh to us at ask us at
simplenon.net also uh once your
application is submitted we it will go
for a review and based on the review
we'll be calling you for the admissions
call and also we'll be sending you know
admissions offer letter over the mail as
well uh also the price of this program
is uh one lakh 45 000 uh including taxes
and in case you're looking for financing
options it's also available so the Emi
will be as less as 4935 per month uh the
cohort which is upcoming and starting uh
is on 7th October the induction will
happen and the classes for this one will
start on 11th of November uh also just
to let you know that we have very
limited seats we only take like 25 to 30
Forks per se per program uh because we
want to make sure that they get the all
attention while uh you know while you
are focusing on completing the
certification also in case you have any
questions related to the program you can
always reach out to us as ask us at
centrino.net
so yeah so folks who have shared their
interest in enrolling the program uh I
we would love to know that how soon are
you planning to enroll so again just one
last rule before we take the Q a
questions uh after this so you can see a
quick poll on the screen uh if you want
to enroll immediately you can choose the
first one we can see within three months
option within six months option and even
from more than six months from now so uh
folks who have already shared their
interest in Rolling the program I would
suggest uh to quickly go and vote on
this last poll of this webinar session
before we take up the Q a questions
so this will help us understand when are
you planning to enroll so accordingly we
you know we can reach out to you so the
current uh basically uh program uh or
has a bonus bonus offer as well
which you'll be getting uh in your
admission letter and also through a
learning consultant who will be calling
uh from Simply run to help you out to uh
take take you through the program as
well in much more detail
so I can see the polls still moving in
so I'll give it some more time 15
seconds for if the folks who have not
voted before we move to the Q a part
which I am looking forward we have
gotten like 100 plus questions there so
uh we have covered like like little bit
of the questions from there uh but we'll
try to take as many questions as
possible so yeah
so I'll be closing the poll in 10
seconds
so
I can see folks are still voting I'll
give five seconds more so five four
three
two one I'll just end the poll uh so uh
we can see that uh a lot of the folks
who want to join immediately and a few
of the folks want to join within three
months or six months and few of them
want to join from uh six months from now
so now uh we are going to what's the Q a
part of the session uh like uh
interesting part of the session is that
we have started reading questions even
before the session started Paris like
people were putting non-questions so
that is why we have a lot of questions
they have a lot of curiosity towards
cyber security and taking that up as a
career so maybe meanwhile let's start
with few questions
so let me just uh
check out questions here
okay
okay we can see one question uh um what
what are the job opportunities for BCA
students in cyber security field
schedule
so so I think from a BCA standpoint you
have an understanding of the basic ID
systems how the computer software Works
how the operating system works how the
memory management works so
this course would enable you to build on
top of the skills that you have already
got under BCA and that will help you in
really contextualizing those skills when
I I remember when I started for the
operating system it was a theory to me
in terms of how the memory management
works but then when I landed myself into
cyber security I could realize that how
those Concepts that I started in my
earlier btec or the bachelor's course
how those resonates back to the tools
that we use in the cyber security and
why those concepts are important from a
foundational standpoint so I think the
BCA would definitely be an aid into uh
into building up your cyber security
career for sure
wow awesome thank you so much Paris for
the answer uh I hope that answers your
question I couldn't get the mean uh also
uh okay is it memory to have a network
in linear background uh I have 15 years
of experience as quality Auditor in ID
do I need to change my field so I think
as asked
so you do not so a depending upon the
profession that you are choosing it can
be a mandatory to have a network
security background or a network
Administration background or it cannot
be so for example if I want to do a pen
test on the application I need not know
about the network at all uh basic
understanding would be good enough for
me which is any which way is getting
covered in this course uh if I want to
be a infrastructure penetration tester
then absolutely I need to have the
networking understanding and a good
understanding of a networking
Administration as well which will help
me in identifying the vulnerabilities
and exploiting those as well if I want
to be into a privacy side of it I need
not possess any working technology skill
at all so it totally depends on which
field or which discipline you want to
get into from a cyber security
standpoint and depending on that you may
or may not have a relevance of a network
Administration as a background the
second part of it is uh if you are
already working into a particular domain
for 15 years
and you want to move into cyber security
I would say take your uh best judgment
because you've already invested so much
of your time and career into one
particular field if you believe that
there is no growth in that particular
domain Beyond a certain limit that you
have already grown then you can evaluate
cyber security as a career option
because for cyber security you would be
a new entrant into the domain uh though
it would not be a completely new domain
for you and the industry would not look
at it from a fresher standpoint as well
but then you may not get that Advantage
into immediate joining uh from a cyber
security standpoint so you may need to
invest certain more into cyber security
and the best suited profession for you
would be either into an audit or into a
compliance related job from a cyber
security standpoint those disciplines
would be able to appreciate your
experience into the quality and they
would they would be able to Benchmark
you on their salary standards as well or
their leveling standards as well based
on your experience I would I would not
recommend you to go into a technology
domain from a cyber security standpoint
at this career Junction
uh oh thank you so much Paris for the
answer uh Swati I hope that helps you
out uh also I can see one uh question uh
from uh okay I cannot see the name uh so
I'll just read out the question so dear
team I worked as a sap consultant for
two years uh I have a career gap of more
than three years till now I wanted to
move into cyber security now I'm already
attending uh AEP a PCS program from
triple it Bangalore by simply learn uh
will I be able to enter into cyber
security field just after finishing the
course uh or should I update my uh
myself more with any other
certifications it would be really
helpful to receive your suggestions
thank you in advance
so I think this course is is one such
course which is putting together all the
Practical learnings into it uh
there are different courses which are
available like for example it can range
from a ceh perspective where where you
learn all the tools practically in just
a matter of three four days or five days
and you learn you do not learn much out
of it uh then there are courses like
offensive security which are like really
really Advanced course which gives you a
kind of a video learning experience so
you get the recording you have to go
through the recording and then apply
those recordings or learnings into the
Practical exam
but I think this is one such course
where you have a mix of both the world
so you get a Hands-On exposure using the
tool it's not a very very short-term
course where you just come learn the
tool and then go back I think this
particular engagement or this particular
learning gives you the experience
overall and it's a journey that you
start with understanding the cyber
security as a concept taking on
different discipline and cyber security
doing things practically and then
applying those in a Capstone project as
well so this is
I would say this is a much more
structured learning and this should
definitely help you in getting a job
role in the organizations
thank you Paris for the answer like I
hope that helps you uh I can see one
question from Kieran here is coding
important for cyber security
again it depends uh if you are
interested in doing a code level review
of the Cyber or of an application then
having a developer background or a
coding background definitely helps so I
would say if you do not have a coding
background do not launch yourself into
an application side of it uh don't go
into application security testing or the
code testing as well but then you can
also look at streams like sock you can
look at the streams like pen testers for
the infrastructure you can look yourself
for the forensics investigation and so
on where you do not need much of a
developer background uh in cyber
security having a developer background
obviously helps but doesn't necessarily
means that you need to have a skill
related to it if you have a basic
understanding of it and not engaging in
the application side of it it is still
workable
I would like to know about the career
roadmap in cyber security domain
presently I am working as a technical
manager uh it inference since last more
than 10 years present company is
planning to launch cyber security
division in which we may pitch SAS
vulnerability assessments bapt Etc and
solutions I may get an opportunity but I
do not have an expertise in cyber
security how can I prepare myself and
how would be our career roadmap regards
vinayak so I think first of all you need
to possess an understanding of cyber uh
you are already working as a technical
manager into an organization so whenever
the role opens up they would expect you
to know the Cyber as a subject so that
is the first and the foremost
requirement the second thing is there
can be multiple streams at your levels
for example you can be a vulnerability
manager wherein the vulnerability kind
of collate gets collated at your end and
then you triage those vulnerabilities
out to say these ones gets the phase one
fix these one gets a phase two fix and
so on
so you can be a vulnerability manager
you can be a overall risk manager as
well wherein you are running a
department or you are running a team to
determine what are the risks available
in the overall technology
you can be a lead for let's say a
technical team as well wherein you and
you yourself are not performing the
technical engagements but then you are
directing the team in doing so and while
they are performing those technical
engagements you are reviewing their work
and then you are presenting that to a
CSO office or the CIO office so there
are a lot of engagements that you can do
at your level with your background since
you are already working as a technical
manager so you would have a upper hand
from a technology understanding
perspective so you would know the
technology is just that building on top
of it with the with the cyber security
knowledge
thank you so much Paris for answering
that I hope that answers your question
vinayak uh so we have gotten one
question from Khan uh difference between
threat vulnerability and risk is in your
own words and the experience till now uh
you have achieved I think that's a great
portion that's a very very fundamental
but yet uh very textbook answers is
something that you find it on the on the
internet see I think vulnerability is is
a stepping stone to anything and
everything so vulnerability is just like
a weakness it can be a human weakness uh
for example I drive car really fast
that's a weakness now
the vulnerability is I can't really
control my emotions when I'm behind the
steering wheel and that's a
vulnerability that I have uh similarly
the the vulnerability can lead to a
threat uh threat if I have to Define is
like a burglary getting happen in your
house because you have windows so you
have Windows as a vulnerability somebody
can throw a stone and that can break the
window pane and then somebody can enter
into it and steal some stuff out so the
threat is really a burglary that can
happen
a risk is something which gets a
magnitude of impact because of a thread
getting exercise or the vulnerability
getting exploited
now if if I look at one time impact it
is like
10 kgs of gold though I don't have that
much of gold with me but let's say a 10
kilogram of goal getting stolen from my
house
now that's a one-time impact but if I
still do not recover from my mistake if
I still put a new glass pane onto my
house and with the same features same
look and feel same strength then
tomorrow the theft can happen again so
the vulnerability still exists the
threat of burglary still exists and the
exploitation can still happen so over a
period of time if I look at my risk
there is a risk of life because I'm not
I'm not I'm not learning from the
mistake so there's a risk of life that
can happen plus there is a risk that
every time a kind of a theft happens
there's something or the other getting
stolen from my house So eventually at
the end of six months or one month or a
year I can end up on quantifying the
thread and that is what the risk from a
quantification standpoint from a
qualification standpoint the risk is a
threat to life so so yeah that's that's
how I see a vulnerability threat and the
risk
uh thank you so much for asking that I
hope that answers your question uh we I
can see one question from ankur here I'm
working as a business analyst and I want
to move my career in cyber security what
is the best feeling to go
the best field to go is into a risk
assessment you are already into a field
where you have an understanding of a
business systems end to end and you are
interacting with the business owners you
are collecting the requirements uh
you're working on those requirements and
probably translating those requirements
into a technology terms as well for the
application team or the other teams to
understand so I think the best position
for you would be in a risk related
domain where you would continue to work
with the business stakeholders
understanding their perspectives the
applications the ID systems and then the
processes and then coming up with the
framework of the risk and understanding
what the risk looks like for an
organization and then Translating that
to the technology team so that they can
go ahead and fix the issues on the
ground
well that's great I hope uh uncle that
answers your question uh let us take uh
maybe a few more questions because we
have gotten if we're still getting
questions uh so uh this is a very common
question coming from everywhere
basically uh a career roadmap for
beginners in cyber security
so I would say the the career
looks really really interesting so I
think from from today's market
perspective first of all you have a lot
of options uh to start your career or
launch yourself into a cyber security
domain
start with a basic or basic role I would
say of being into a compliance because
that will help you in understanding what
the cyber security is
if you are starting up in a technical
domain or a technology domain
from this certification or from this
particular course you would know how to
carry out a penetration testing for
example so you can be a good
vulnerability assessor or you can be a
technical assessor into a Consulting
organization like the big fours or other
Consulting organizations which work into
a security domain so you can be really
an asset to them as well
so you have two streams to choose one a
compliance where you are kind of a
security analyst or a business security
analyst and then the second stream is
more towards technically oriented where
you are starting as a security
consultant into a Consulting
organization
thank you so much Paris for explaining
that uh so we have one common question
again like uh so folks who have done uh
basically cyber security crows from
Simply learn uh you know uh so they're
asking that uh when they're going
towards you know uh searching for a job
or an internship uh what are the tips
you would give them you know in order to
prepare for that as well
for sorry I didn't get the question
Russia Yeah so basically uh I can see a
common question coming in for folks who
have done uh basically are doing or have
done the course from Simply learn in
cyber security uh like what would you
suggest then uh in terms of like you
know when they are going for a job or uh
internship uh how would you suggest them
to prepare like in terms of tips post uh
getting uh knowledge or certification of
cyber security so I would say from an
interview standpoint there are some
fundamental mistake that each one of us
do so we both start CV a lot I think we
should stop doing it we should start
putting something which we are really
confident upon uh we may have worked on
to that particular domain or we may not
have but at least we should have a
really Hands-On understanding of
whatever we are writing on the CV or a
curriculum now what happened when we
interviewed today let's say in Microsoft
what we really look in is what an
individual CV talks about what are the
tools the person has written what are
the Frameworks the individual is talking
about what are the compliances the
individual has worked upon what are the
technologies that the person has really
experienced upon and we try to answer or
we try to ask the questions around
something which is written in the CE
so if we are
not if you are not
trusting ourselves and if we are putting
incorrect information into our CV I
think that's the first mistake that we
do we should stop doing it
uh if we have learned something in a
cyber security course or a certification
if you are very confident on that
particular topic like like I talked
about the nist framework that I adopted
I was hell confident about it right and
I used it to my uh attribute but then
having said so if we are confident about
a topic even though we have not
experienced it but we are very very
confident about it go ahead and attend
the interview the more interviews you
attend see what is the worst outcome
that can happen you will face a
rejection what is the best outcome that
can happen you will get selected so it's
either ways you so it's 50 50 chance so
you have both the options of getting uh
of securing a place and of not securing
a place the the bright side is the more
interviews you attend the more library
of questions you would build
and the more library of portions you
would have the more prepared you would
be for the real final one where you will
get a selection so don't be afraid of uh
the rejection those are just the
stepping stones and just face them with
the courage and just keep preparing on
the library of questions that are being
asked to you or put forward to you in
the interviews uh start to kind of
scribble about your TV start to polish
your CV based on the experience that you
get in the interview so that in the next
interview you don't face those questions
again so yeah that's a mantra
well that's that's great thank you so
much Paris I think we have a lot of
questions but we'll take one last
question I can see one question from
Snee Shankar I am working on uh I am
which is part of cyber security as
project manager uh what would be the
best career path for me
so there are two career paths that I can
suggest one can be of continuing in the
IIM field
um and that is like you are project
manager right now uh you can become a
program manager in tomorrow's time so
that's that's one suggestion second if
you do not want to pursue on being a
project manager and you are
conversant about the IIM technology
you can get into the architect role as
well and uh I am being a very very
integral part of the Integrations that
we do you are you are best suited for
the architectural team so yeah these are
the two career paths that you can
evaluate
awesome uh thank you so much Paris for
answering that question we can see that
SNES responded also on chat thank you
Paris really appreciate it we are
getting a lot of thank you as Paris uh
while you're answering their questions
as well so I think this is the last one
I'm so sorry folks we have already
extended like by 40 minutes a session
because of the demand uh we have uh so
they want to ask you a lot of questions
as far as what we have to enter session
maybe uh we can do another one uh next
month if you're available so we'll do
that and thank you so much Paris for
taking the time out and uh you know
answering these questions you know folks
which have about cyber security as a
career and uh about this program as well
thank you so much Paris for joining us
uh so yeah would you like to see
something to the crowd before we leave
I think I think thanks to everyone who
stayed late uh I still see about 84
participants uh extending the session
and I really love the uh the energy that
this particular group has brought to the
table I think the group has been
fantastically participative and thank
you Russia for organizing the entire
session and stitching it together really
appreciate that and would be happy to
take on certain questions if there are
any on an email as well so if somebody
can just kind of put together into an
email I would be able to answer those as
well
details here as well in case they want
to reach out to you if they have any
questions here uh so I can see uh
someone responding on chat here that I
missed some part of the session so
there's a chance yes you will get the
recording as you'll get the recording
post webinar and you can view it you can
take your time you can listen to Paris
you know he's answered so many so many
questions here which might help you out
uh if you're planning to take up take
this up as a career uh and you can
always ask us at uh ask us at
simpleton.net if you have any queries
and also you can scan this code here to
you know this will take you to the
program page as well so thank you so
much everyone you have been a great
great audience a very interactive one
and uh yeah like I'm so sorry if we were
not able to take your question we'll
take it in the next session or you can
always you know like uh reach out to
Paris as well as you said you know if
you have any questions as well thank you
so much we'll be ending the session now
thank you Paris thank you once again
thank you Russia thanks everyone take
care
thank you